the shortest game in professional league
of Legends history is the story of a
charming outlaw unrequited love a
heartful memorial yes and the bitter
fury of a game developer scorned john
doe san gil was once revered as one of
the greatest league of legends players
in the world
he conquered soloqueue taking the top
spot in both Korea and China all while
playing for positions at the same time
the sick thing about though is he can
play practically every single role in
the game and be good enough to get
accounts super high up in challenger now
that's not even the case for faker
but after wasn't trying to go pro after
was a listing app that would take your
money and boost your count all the way
to the highest ratio of soloqueue all
while maintaining his own fantastic
record obviously ride them like that
rights generally not a fan of when
people mess with the competitive
integrity of their game so whenever they
gathered up enough evidence of Aptos ela
leu think they'd ban him but then after
would show up on a new account and the
chase would start all over again
the money was good but there wasn't any
glory in it
faker had just come off his rookie
season World Championship win meanwhile
opto the king of Korean soloqueue was
running and hiding from riot he wasn't
getting a chance to test his mettle on
stage against Korea's best
so after gathered up a few friends from
solo queue and formed team dark led by
their misfit hero they would compete in
the pandoro champions winter 2013 to
2014 qualifiers and if they made it they
would give apto a chance to show that he
had what it took to go toe-to-toe with
the best players in the world
but the day before the offline
qualifiers riot band apto from playing
in professional tournaments for two
years and banned his main account for a
thousand years that's not a joke he's
literally banned for playing league of
legends until the year three thousand
and thirteen allegedly this had to do
with a girl who came to apto for ela
boosting but when she developed feelings
for him he turned her down and she
turned him in team dark was forced to
play without act oh and though they made
it into Champions it just didn't seem
like their hearts were in it anymore
they lost app though their charismatic
soloqueue rebel leader and without him
they kind of fell apart in their second
game against Samsung ozone team dark
went fool me this is a troll game guys
they drafted an all jungler composition
in honor of the then recently retired
korean jungler cloudtemplar tube temple
RC + team dark spelled out let's go gank
if you read out the first characters
other bands champions names team nerfs
comp was never supposed to be in a lane
so samsung ozone went just as mean they
drafted all ad carries and breezers
designed to push lanes and take towers
as fast as possible i'm curious as to
how they're going to play this out with
the Summoner well guys tell your friend
this is a cloudtemplar tribute game I
know Jan Champions winter they
annihilated team dark in just over 8
minutes
if you thought invades are strong last
game you haven't seen the 4 machete
invade how fast can you kill a level 1
dragon I'm ready I'm ready and we're all
laughing Jen is well three days later
KeSPA no Jen disqualified team dark for
intentionally throwing their matches and
as far as anyone knows none of those
players ever played Pro League of
Legends ever again team dark probably
had it coming if you think about it it's
the highest level of League of Legends
competition in the world
is maybe not the best place for your
memorial mean comp but team dart didn't
care they just lost
Abdo and while he'd eventually returned
to solo queue he still banned from
playing under his own name
the 31st century his teamates careers
were forever ruined but they were also
just soloqueue randos for his part Aptos
streams on other accounts now and says
he'll pay right $100,000 to get his main
one back but Wright has every right to
take apart ello boosters these days
after mostly streams from China after
winning a contest that song takes first
place in the solo key rankings there and
also resulted in the single greatest
picture in eSports history but at this
competitive man and then in 2015 there's
no reason he couldn't try out for a pro
team right now but after doesn't care he
doesn't want to play in riot system once
upon a time he was the greatest mid
laner in the world but now he's just a
guy playing League of Legends with a
plate full of money
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button